les réactions politiques se multiplient
en france depuis la révélation de la
sphère des tac appelant au meurtre et au
viol de policiers en échange de primes
ont été retrouvés vendredi sur les murs
d'un immeuble de savigny-le-temple en
seine et marne une ville classée en
zones de sécurité prioritaire une
enquête est en cours afin de retrouver
les auteurs le ministre de l'intérieur
s'est rendu sur place ce dimanche david
khalifa
cinq cent mille euros pour couper la
tête d'un policier ou violet une
policière de 100 euros pour une boule de
pétanque buté sur les forces de l'ordre
ou encore cent mille euros pour je cite
rafales et un policier avec une
kalachnikov voilà le type d'inscription
et ses habitants de savigny-le-temple
ont pu lire ce week-end sur le mur de
leur immeuble c'est dans le hall de ce
point dean que les forces de l'ordre
sont tombés nez à nez avec ce tableau de
primes simple provocation ou véritable
mise à prix l' affaire est prise très au
sérieux par les fonctionnaires qui
travaillent dans sept villes classées en
zones de sécurité prioritaire une
enquête va être ouverte et le ministre
l'intérieur gérald darmanin est venu en
personne leur apporter son soutien je
suis du ce dimanche matin accompagné
même le maire et monsieur le député
rembourser les policiers
c'est tout les six courageux la police
nationale parce qu'ils ont été attaqués
les attaquants on apprend alors violent
à leurs meurtres non
d'attaqué ou via les offres de la
république mon premier devoir avec les
élites de course fine sans vendre sur et
leurs soutiens qu'il n'ya pas ne peut
pas y avoir de provocation comme celle
ci qui reste gratuit on peut dire que la
police irait saisie par le parquet du
coup cette affaire afin que nous
retrouvions nos responsables et grâce
notamment aux nouveaux défis a pu créer
de pouvoir poursuivre ces personnes qui
menacent les positions du côté des
syndicats d'urgence est bel et bien réel
l'inquiétude se fait ressentir de
manière générale partout en france et
pas seulement dans ces quartiers dits
sensibles
ces tags se multiplient avec parfois les
noms et les photos facebook des membres
des forces de l'ordre beaucoup sont
montés au créneau pour dénoncer ces
faits y réclamer davantage de moyens
pour punir les auteurs de tels actes
qu'attend-t-on pour faire quelque chose
on recevait des jets de pierres et
aujourd'hui on passe encore un cran
supplémentaire dans la violence le
climat devient de plus en plus
inquiétant on sort d'un bon vous de la
sécurité les réponses se font toujours
attendre sur le sujet des décisions de
justice la peur changera de camp à la
seule condition que la justice suive le
travail policier dès lors que
l'infraction est caractérisée mort d'un
policier rafale et la police à la
kalachnikov violet rentrée une barre
dans l'utérus d'une femme policière ces
ordures ont la chance que les policiers
soient bridées par les instructions
sinon ça fait longtemps qu'on aurait
fait le ménage alors insiste t on
réellement une accélération de ce
phénomène ces derniers temps dans
l'hexagone mi octobre à
vigneux-sur-seine déjà dans l'essonne
des inscriptions de menaces et
d'insultés visant des policiers
nommément avaient été découverts dans
les parties communes d'un immeuble avant
cela en août dernier à poitiers des tags
du même type avait été signalée les
enquêteurs avaient même découvert la
photo de la fille d'un policier dans le
téléphone d'un suspect placé en garde à
vue la défiance vis-à-vis de la police
interpelle à ce rythme il semble
probable qu'elle ne devrait pas tarder à
devenir un sujet incontournable de la
campagne présidentielle